[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question--
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
We have an exciting show
for you today.
We'll talk about gaming.
But first, let me introduce
our guests.
My co-host in the studio
here is Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: Hello,
everyone.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: Pretty
good, pretty good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Have
a good weekend?
JEREMY WALKER: I did.
I got some sleep.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Have you
played a bunch of games?
JEREMY WALKER: I have.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
we'll talk about that.
On my left, Cliff Samaniego.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Hello.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Hi, Cliff.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO:
How's it going?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Going good.
How is your gaming going?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Gaming
is going well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, cool.
We have Kenji Arai.
Kenji is a world-famous
mobile gamer.
KENJI ARAI: What.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: He
beats every record.
KENJI ARAI: I try, but fail
miserably, usually.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And they'll
talk about YouTube gaming.
They're both from our gaming
business development
organization.
And on the Hangout, we
have Jeffrey Posnick.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Hey, everybody.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How's life
in New York, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: It's
doing pretty well.
You can see the lovely, lush
background over here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Still
summertime in New York?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, yes,
which is not always pleasant,
but it's been pretty
good right now.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So let's go to it.
One word of warning--
since Cliff and Kenji work in
business development, they
refused to come without
the deck.
So they need a presentation
in order to
structure their thoughts.
And I think this is just a sign
of their professionalism.
So what we'll do is it will
be more of a webinar slash
discussion-style presentation
today.
And really, the reason why we
wanted to talk to you about
game integration is
because gaming is
really big on YouTube.
But there's still challenges
from a technical standpoint
with respect to integration
between your game and our
YouTube APIs.
And then also, not everyone
knows about all the
opportunities that exist for
game developers when it comes
to really taking advantage
of our platform--
such as monetization,
additional
analytics, and so forth.
So this is what Cliff and
Kenji will cover.
And then we'll also show you a
bunch of cool gameplay videos,
because obviously, we can't
have a show without seeing
some YouTube videos.
And later on, Jeff will
cover a couple of
important blog posts.
I know all the people watching
today have read our blog posts
because they are read in
real time as we post
them, right, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: Exactly.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I know
Jeremy does that.
But just in case, we're
going to have Jeff
cover that for you.
So how does the agenda sound?
JEREMY WALKER: Sounds
pretty good to me.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds
all right?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Kick
it off, Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Let's get to it.
So let me jump to the
presentation.
And we are sharing it right
here in the Hangout.
We'll make that deck available
for you later on.
And let's just go
through this.
So here is our agenda.
We'll chat about the game
publishers that have
integrated with YouTube.
I'll give you some examples.
I'll talk about the benefits of
integration, like what you
actually get out of it.
Cover some best practices,
both pre-launch and
post-launch.
So Cliff and Kenji have been
working with game publishers
for quite a while.
So they have amassed a body of
knowledge that we hope to
share with you today.
And we'll chat about some of the
implementation mechanisms
for both console games and
mobile games, some best
practices in this area.
And if you are watching this
live, we have a moderator link
in the YouTube video
description.
So if you click on that
link, you can submit
questions to us.
And Jeremy will go through
them one by one and
answer all of them.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes,
definitely.
We already have a couple, so
we're keeping an eye on that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So,
Cliff, tell us more
about gaming and YouTube.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah, so
we've had a number of
different integrations,
primarily with a lot of game
publishers.
Most of them are console,
but some of them are PC.
In the last couple years,
we've had a number of
different game titles.
Some of them include Call of
Duty, for example, both Black
Ops as well as Modern
Warfare 3.
We've integrated with Team
Fortress 2 as well as Dirt 3,
as well as NBA 2K12, Uncharted
3, as well as
PlayStation at Home.
And all of them have been
very, very different API
integrations.
But gaming is such a visceral
and video-centric thing that
in order to actually feel the
game, it's a great experience
for game publishers to integrate
with our APIs and
then upload them to YouTube.
Kenji, did you have anything
to add to that?
KENJI ARAI: No, I think users
want to share their
achievements, want to
share their fails.
It definitely gets a lot
of views on YouTube.
So giving the users the ability
to do so freely--
you're actually pretty surprised
what you find and
kind of the creativity
from the users.
So giving them the tools really
does kind of allow them
to express themselves and a lot
of them play their games.
And that's the way they
participate on YouTube.
So we hope that more publishers
and developers
integrate with our APIs.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah,
we wanted to just
show you some examples.
It's really hard to imagine.
I think the best way to really
picture what we're doing, in
terms of the API integrations
with the consoles and PC
games, is to check them out in
terms of the game captures
that have been uploaded to
YouTube by a lot of users.
So, here's a good example--
Team Fortress 2.
They actually did a pretty
good integration.
It's coming from a PC title.
And then also, they managed
to do a really good award
competition.
So they tried to capture some
of the best uploads coming
from the API, which really
encouraged engagement with a
lot of the users.
So here's an example
of Team Fortress 2.
And this is the one
that actually, I
believe, won the award.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Best overall.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Best overall.
And this one's called
"El Muchacho."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In a land without law, one man
will make a stand in the
name of justice.
And his name is El Muchacho.
[GUNFIRE AND EXPLOSIONS]
-XLR 105 Production presents
El Muchacho.
Coming to a theater near you.
Valve time.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: That
was pretty cool.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: And here's
an example from Black Ops.
Did you want to go to that?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, so let's
talk a little bit about
Black Ops and then we'll
show the example.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: So Black Ops,
so far in terms of our API,
has been the most successful.
We integrated this in late
2010, early 2011.
And Activision was really,
really happy with the
integration.
Just within the span of four
months, we had 4 million
uploads and 70 million views
of those uploads, so very,
very successful.
I think a lot of users were very
encouraged by seeing a
lot of their highlights
uploaded to YouTube.
So it really fed into more
people uploading and more
people watching those
particular videos.
Activision was really, really
happy with the integration.
They even spoke with us, both at
Google I/O as well as GDC.
So here's an example of
one of the uploads
coming from Black Ops.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Did you
do this one, Cliff?
Or is it user-generated
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: That's
user-generated.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KENJI ARAI: [INAUDIBLE]
Normally, the missile
would hit me.
[LAUGHTER]
[EXPLOSION]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: So these are
just very, very interesting
moments that people have
within a game.
And generally, if you don't
integrate with an API and
upload it to YouTube, it's just
something that you're
sharing with the people
within the room.
However, when you're able to
upload it through our API and
up to YouTube, you're able
to share that video.
Because it's captured, it's on
demand, and you can share your
infamy with others.
KENJI ARAI: Yeah, and I think
publishers and developers can
really take advantage of
everybody's social graph,
whether it's putting it on
Google+, Twitter, Facebook.
Users want to share those
moments with their friends.
If I captured me jumping over
a missile, I would certainly
be bragging about it
with my friends.
Like I said, a missile would
likely hit me, but I would
probably share that moment
with my friends, too.
But I think publishers and
developers want to be in this
sort of social environment, and
really taking advantage of
users kind of doing that leg
work for them and sharing it
with their close friends, with
the people that kind of follow
them through whatever their
social mechanisms are, I think
is really important.
And I think video can be a
really big anchor point for
publishers to take advantage
of through their fans.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: And before
we kick off this next
gameplay of Dirt 3--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh, come on,
Cliff, I want to watch it now.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Before we watch
this, I mean, imagine
that you haven't even heard of
Dirt 3, or even knew about the
game Dirt 3 from Codemasters,
and then watching something
like this on YouTube.
More often than not, it's going
to speak for itself in
terms of the graphics and
the gameplay and the
mechanics of the game.
So this is a really good
marketing and promotional
tool, as Kenji said, for a lot
of the game publishers.
So let's watch the--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Can we
see it now, Cliff?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
KENJI ARAI: Roll it,
roll it, roll it.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: All right,
waiting for the
massive crash here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Is this
how you drive, Kenji?
KENJI ARAI: This is the exact
opposite of how I drive.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This is
how you want to drive.
KENJI ARAI: This is not how
I want to drive with
my kid in the car.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh,
now I get it.
KENJI ARAI: Yeah, I don't
think my daughter would
appreciate this roll.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Ouch.
But you survived, right?
It was all good.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: So that's
a great example.
If I never have heard of Dirt
3 and never played the game,
this might be actually an
avenue for me to get
interested in the game
and playing the game
and buying the game.
And I think that's a lot of
what we're trying to do in
terms of helping out game
publishers, is get front and
center of our huge gaming
audience within YouTube and
tapping into that audience.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So what do they get out of it?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Kenji, you
want to cover promotion?
KENJI ARAI: I think we kind of
talked about it in this one,
where I think you allow
the YouTube
audience, which is what--
I think, 800 million
plus strong now--
the opportunity to discover
new game titles.
Google is the number
one search engine.
YouTube is the number
two search engine.
And so people are always
constantly looking for things.
And depending on what type of
metadata you're really using
to capture those when you're
uploading gameplay footage
through the API, you can
maximize your discovery
through the metadata and
things like that.
So you really just kind of
let your users make your
promotional outlets for you.
And I think that's kind of
the powerful thing to do.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
that's all good.
Now show me the money.
KENJI ARAI: Show
you the money.
Yeah, we do.
We do have options for game
publishers and developers to
actually participate in
ad-supported content.
So anything that does come
through your technology, your
API integration with us, we
actually allow you to claim
that content and
put ads on it.
And you can create sort of an
incremental revenue stream.
And when you start thinking
about the long tail of content
and millions and millions of
uploads and all those views
that kind of compile on top of
it, you start to do the math
in your head.
Where maybe the resources that
you put into it get paid, paid
in full, all the way back, even
more so, with some of the
revenues that you can make.
Not to mention the users that
you'll be able to discover and
potentially engage
with later on.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So say
I'm a game developer.
I build a game.
I want to monetize
that content.
What do I do?
Do I call you, or do I post
online for help, or--
KENJI ARAI: I think right now
my cell phone number's going
to come up right here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Do I need
to sign anything?
How does the process work?
Because this is one of the areas
that I think frequently
developers have a hard
time understanding.
For content owners, we have
YouTube partnership program
where you go to
youtube.com/partner, sign up,
and get vetted.
So how does the app developer
approach this?
What's the actual process?
KENJI ARAI: I think, first
things first, we want to know
who you are.
So I think, Jarek, you can
provide sort of an alias that
folks can email into to kind of
at least give us a little
bit of a pipeline of who
potentially are interested in
such a program like this.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You guys--
just to interrupt you--
if you're watching this and you
are a game developer, just
ping our Google developers
page.
And we'll hook you up
with these guys.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah.
And then keep in mind that if
you're interested in using the
APIs, you don't necessarily have
to be a partner, right?
You can use our APIs
regardless.
But if you want to monetize
your content--
meaning monetize the UGC
uploads that are
coming from the API--
then you're going to have
to become a partner.
And there's definitely
agreements that we need to
sign with you in order to start
monetizing those uploads.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So how does
it work from a license
perspective?
Some publishers grant users
the license to basically
upload and monetize
themselves.
Others don't.
Is that something that an
application developer has to
think up front?
Or is this something that
the publisher does?
What is the process before they
even sign up with the
partnership program?
Are there any gotchas--
things to consider upfront?
KENJI ARAI: I think ultimately
what you want to make sure is
who owns the rights
to the content.
There are definitely game titles
out there where the
developer has sort of given the
rights to the users to do
whatever they want with.
Now, obviously, there's
some pros and cons
that come with that.
But for the most part, what
Cliff and I see is--
I think there is pretty normal
language within most terms of
service, terms of use, where the
rights still go with the
publishers or the developers.
And so unless the publisher or
developer then grants users
rights, it can be a little bit
of a sticky situation for
users to monetize
it on their own.
Although there are definitely
a lot of users who monetize
gameplay footage on YouTube,
thanks to various different
partnerships that some of our
content creators have with the
publishers and developers.
So I think ultimately, when you
think about your content,
it's not just about the gameplay
and the game footage
that you guys create within
the game, just in terms of
playing the game.
I think what you want to think
about is when people create
content, show their gameplay,
who kind of owns it-- and then
what benefits are you kind of
granting your users, taking
for yourselves, I guess,
is a thing
that you want to consider.
And I think-- to add to
what Cliff said--
it's not just about
monetizing.
It is about sort of being able
to gain analytics from all
that gameplay that gets put
onto YouTube as well.
So that--
yes, showing the money.
It's certainly something that
you may be interested in-- but
I think really getting closer
to your users is something
that's even a bigger priority
for a lot of people
that we work with.
The money is sort of a
secondary, third priority, but
it's kind of a nice-to-have.
But ultimately, really getting
close to the users and finding
out like-- there's that one
person who all of a sudden has
half a million views, a million
views for something
that they did.
Maybe the game developer, game
publisher, wants to reach out
to that person and form a more
formal relationship with that
person, so--
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah, I would
say that analytics are also a
hugely important piece of the
puzzle for a lot of the game
publishers.
Monetization is great.
Everybody wants to make
a little bit of money.
However, there's a lot of users
and a lot of videos that
are on YouTube that you don't
really have insight to.
But if you're uploading and
claiming those videos from the
API, now you have a lot of
insight in terms of who's
playing your game, how they're
playing your game, what
moments they feel are the best
moments within the game.
KENJI ARAI: Absolutely.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: So it's a
really good feature set for a
lot of game publishers to
tap into that audience.
KENJI ARAI: Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: As a YouTube
partner, are there any
additional analytics that can be
obtained if you are in the
partnership program?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Are
there additional--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Reports, or
how does it compare with a
long-tail developer
that just uses
standard terms of service?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: They will
probably receive the same
analytics that a regular user
who has a channel has.
You're basically going
to get demographics.
You're going to get
video view counts.
You're going to learn where
a lot of those viewers are
coming from in terms
of geography.
You're going to learn what are
the most popular videos and
see how many view counts
those have had.
KENJI ARAI: I think the one
thing that is different,
though, is when you're actually
making a claim on a
piece of content, we can
actually give you that
additional information.
But if you are simply using our
APIs kind of outside of a
partnership--
because there isn't a lot of
claiming that's going on,
where you're basically tagging
a video saying you own that
IP, it kind of goes off into the
YouTube corpus and kind of
exists on the platform.
But you won't actually be able
to see the granular data
that's actually on the screen
right now, on the analytics,
very business-y slide that
Jarek has put up.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Which
I stole from Cliff.
KENJI ARAI: I see these have the
up-and-to-the-right, the
graph-- although there is
a dip in the green line.
But I'll try not to worry
about that one.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, so
I think the important
distinction is that if you are a
partner and a content owner,
then you can actually have
analytics that span multiple
accounts into which the content
is being uploaded.
Versus if you use the developer
key and you
associate these uploads
with a developer key.
Yes, you still can get analytics
as far as kind of
number of uploads, but there's
not as much information about
the views and demographics.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah, OK.
I see what you were
getting at.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Users account.
That was a tricky question.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: You threw
a curveball at me, Jarek.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm just
making sure that you don't
only play games for
a living, man.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: You're
supposed to throw up
volleyballs--
KENJI ARAI: That's why you
invited me to this--
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: So I
can spike them down.
KENJI ARAI: In the system--
it's in the screenshot right
here-- this is also the system
that would give you sort of
access to the top video.
You could filter out by all
the tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands,
4 million videos.
You can sort it by who's
getting the most views.
And then potentially reaching
out to that user directly on
YouTube and seeing what they're
all about and seeing
if they might be able to help
you guys out even further.
Like I said, you guys can
potentially create a more
formal relationship with
your user community.
But sometimes, it's just hard to
find out who they actually
are without doing searches
and things of a
manual nature on YouTube.
So this actually really
helps automate that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, speaking
of community, I think
this site has a nice example of
what Valve did with their
user-generated Apple capability,
where they would
grant additional items to
players that reached certain
milestones on YouTube really
to entice them to upload.
So there's a lot of creative
work being done by kind of
gamifying the YouTube experience
for the players.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah, I mean
there's just a lot of ways in
which game publishers can reach
out to the community
once you have a lot of
content on YouTube.
The slide was mentioning a
number of different things
that you could do, such
as curating playlists.
Curating playlists-- so you
can have best shots, for
example, if it's Call of
Duty, or best crashes,
if it was Dirt 3.
So there's a number of different
things that you can
do with the API and use the
data API to curate and
automate those playlists.
And then, as Jarek was saying,
you could also reach out to
your audience by having
participation
with different contests.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
So Cliff, you--
sorry to interrupt you, but--
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You know, you
guys have been doing this
for a while.
So I wanted to make sure
that we cover the
kind of best practices.
What do you worry about
before you launch?
What do you do after
you launch?
Because it's not kind
of one-shot effort.
So should we go through
some of these steps?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah,
let's dive in.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Your
collective wisdom from the
past couple of years.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yep.
So with pre-launch, there's a
number of things that you
should obviously start
thinking about.
One of them is what is the goal
of having and integrating
the API into your game.
And Kenji went through some
of these-- it might be
monetization, for example.
It might be diving
into analytics of
a lot of your users.
And it might be just developing
engagement with
your community.
So you need to think about what
your goals are, because
then we can tailor the APIs
according to those goals.
Another thing to think about--
and we run into this all the
time with a lot of game
publishers--
is that you need a technical
lead once you decide that
you're going to start diving
into the API and integrating
with YouTube.
And the reason being is there's
a lot to do in terms
of integrating with YouTube.
And so you need a spokesperson
who's going to sort of be the
quarterback to handle all of the
different steps and think
about how to integrate
with YouTube.
In terms of other things--
let me see here.
Another thing is you should
always have an established
YouTube channel.
I think we've run into it--
some game publishers who
didn't have a YouTube channel.
And it's important to have a
YouTube channel so we know
where we can direct some
of the playbacks.
Or if you're curating playlists,
we can put it in,
drop it into the channel.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You were going
to say something, Kenji?
KENJI ARAI: Yeah.
I was probably coughing, too.
Yeah, I think you want
to establish
your presence on YouTube.
I think having a channel and
having a place where we can
put videos is one thing.
But I think it's also
about establishing
who you are on YouTube.
Because you are going to
be talking to people.
You're going to be interacting
with other users
and stuff like that.
And so they're going to want
to see what you're up to,
whether it's your trailers,
sort of
behind-the-scenes stuff.
Let your videos kind of allow
your users and your fans to
get to know who you are.
And then when you interact
with them, it feels more
authentic, like you're
actually part of the community.
So I don't think we can stress
it enough to just sort of
establish your identity
and then participate.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah.
And if you need help in terms of
developing your channel or
launching your channel,
you can always go to
youtube.com/playbook.
And you can download
our playbook.
And it is pretty dense in terms
of all the different
tips and tricks to help
develop your channel.
KENJI ARAI: Yeah, Jarek.
If you think this deck is dense,
you go ahead and check
out our playbook.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I have
checked it out.
It's actually very interesting
for content creators.
I think it's pretty awesome.
JEREMY WALKER: And with
the pre-launch--
KENJI ARAI: Which slide
did you make it to?
JEREMY WALKER: --you still
want them to--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Two.
JEREMY WALKER: --reach
out to you guys--
KENJI ARAI: There's like 100.
JEREMY WALKER: --kind
of talk through?
Have you had many people that
have not reached out to you
and been successful?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Usually what
happens is-- it really depends
on if they're already a YouTube
partner or not.
If they're a YouTube partner,
we're more or less talking to
a lot of our game publishers
on a daily basis.
And then they show their
interest in terms of working
with us with the API
and integrating.
If they're not a partner, more
often than not, it's coming
through Jarek.
And Jarek's the one who's sort
of passing on a lead to us.
And we'll be able to talk
about the partnership.
And then Jarek and his team is
going to handle sort of the
technical side of the API.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, and
we'll definitely help
you out with that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK, so
we launched the game.
Now what?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: In terms of
post-launch, there's a number
of things that you
should look into.
First of all, what we're running
into with a lot of our
API integrations is that they've
done all the technical
work in terms of integrating
with YouTube.
However, they haven't really
gone the step of educating
their users on how to upload
from the game.
And I think this is
really important.
It could be as easy as creating
a video, where you're
walking the user through the
different steps to upload
through your game, and then
posting it onto your channel
on YouTube.
But some of these game capture
feature sets are really buried
within the game.
So it's really important to put
it front and center and
then show people how to actually
upload and the
different steps to upload
to YouTube.
Another thing that we
recommend is curating playlists.
So there is a data API in which
you're going to be able
to take a number of different
metadata and
sort by that metadata.
And so one of things that you
can do is just sort by, for
example, the most viewed or the
most commented and then
create a playlist
out of those.
So that's just one example.
But curating playlists
is really important.
What you want to do is you want
to bubble up the really
good content.
And you want to really empower
your users and have them talk
about your game.
So definitely bubble up the ones
that users already find
interesting.
Another thing is analyze
your data.
We talked a little bit
about one of the
features of the APIs.
And one of the benefits
is the analytics.
But analyze your data.
And try to figure out,
where are your
demographics coming from?
Who are your viewers?
Who are your uploaders?
You could also try
to figure out--
if there's a lull in the
uploads, maybe you want to
push in terms of marketing the
game and market the game at
that sweet spot.
But there's a number of things
that you can figure out with
just looking at your
analytics.
Let me see here.
What else?
Anything you want to
add to that, Kenji?
KENJI ARAI: I was looking at
your five bullet points here.
I think we already talked
about creating contests.
I think it's just about--
after the launch happens, it's
really just diving in with
your community.
Educating your users
how to upload--
what Cliff was referring
to was--
I think when we first launched
the integration with Black
Ops, it was kind of a feature
that was buried a little bit
within Theater Mode.
And luckily we had folks--
I don't know if you're actually
going to show the video--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to go through that.
KENJI ARAI: But we had partners
that were out there
that kind of educated the
community for us, so we were
lucky to have them.
And Jarek will show you
a video of that.
But it's about engaging
with your community.
And so don't just let these
users just upload stuff
mindlessly.
Give them goals and things to
hit, because they're gamers.
They want goals.
They want to hit those levels.
And they want to impress you.
So when you give them something
to aim for, likely
they'll hit it and probably
surprise you with
a little bit more.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Yeah.
And I would just add that-- and
Kenji pretty much spoke to
this, but--
YouTube is a two-way dialogue.
Your users can upload
through the API.
But if you, through your
channel, communicate with them
and say, hey, we'd like to see
more uploads of this type of
kill within Call of Duty--
KENJI ARAI: More headshots.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: --or this
particular move within
Uncharted 3, you're going
to get that response.
Another thing that you can do
is watch the videos that are
being uploaded to YouTube
through the API.
Comment on those videos.
Or you can highlight the videos
that you really like
and put them into your
channel and feature
it within your channel.
These are things that are going
to have that two-way
dialogue with your users.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So let's dive in a little bit
and walk through a couple of
implementation examples.
And if you have some additional
questions about
this section, we actually have
more in-depth presentations
available online.
And we'll post the links to
these after this session.
But we mentioned one integration
that we did
earlier with Call of Duty
Black Ops and now
Modern Warfare 3.
So at Google I/O 2011, we
actually co-presented with
Activision.
And we described how
the system was
built in more detail.
And here's kind of an overview
of how the system worked.
So this is a console
game integration.
It worked for both PlayStation
and the Xbox.
What Activision did is they
actually had a middleware
team, which was actually
responsible for delivering
their videos to YouTube.
So the video was rendered
locally on the console and
then uploaded to their
middleware, which is a team
called DemonWare.
And then from DemonWare, it was
actually pushed using the
API to YouTube.
One thing that they did do is
they actually had a way for
users to link their gaming
account with their YouTube
account through, now, OAuth.
And that allows the
uploads to go into
individuals' user accounts.
And this is something that I
think we can't stress enough.
Frequently, we have partners who
come and insist on trying
to push everything into a
single YouTube channel.
But there are issues
with that.
First of all, you will somewhat
deprive the users of
the sense of ownership of their
own content, so they
won't be able to delete the
video easily if they want to.
And they will have less of
an incentive to share it.
So this is where OAuth comes
into the picture.
You can still have a fair amount
of control over what
the content looks like--
associated metadata
and so forth.
But then the video actually ends
up in the user's account.
And this is the case
with Activision.
They did have an option for
users that didn't have
accounts to actually upload
into a common channel.
But what they found is over
time, most users were actually
incentivized to create these
accounts and link and upload
into their own channel.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: And I think a
lot of the concern with game
publishers is if they, for
example, allow users to upload
into their individual channel,
that there's a sense of loss
of control over those videos.
And one thing that we always
have to remind a lot of the
game publishers is that you can
always grab those videos
and put it into a playlist and
put it into your own channel.
So you can take sort of the
cream of the crop videos and
put them into your channel, but
allow the user to have the
power and control.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, I think
there's always a fine
balance between what the
publisher wants and what the
YouTube community wants
and expects.
So this is a great example where
if it's user-generated
content, our recommendation is
to let users upload it into
their own accounts.
Through a playlist, you can
still curate that content.
You can track it, if you're
actually our YouTube partner.
You can actually obtain the
analytics information.
So all the good things that come
out of the integrations
are possible.
So let's look at the Black Ops
uploads user experiences.
As Kenji mentioned, the initial
version of the game
had it a little buried.
I'm just going to
play this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The only things that you need
are an Xbox 360 or PS3, the
game itself, an internet
connection,
and a YouTube account.
The greatest thing about this
method is that you can do this
all without using a capture card
or any cables or wires.
And most importantly, this
process is all free.
I'm going to go step by step.
And if you still any questions
or comments after I finish,
you can post them below.
And I will do my best
to help you.
The first step is to go to
callofduty.com and register an
account there.
Once you do that, go to
callofduty.com/theater and
link your gamertag, which will
require you using your
Windows Live ID.
Now go back to
callofduty.com/theater.
And on that page, click to link
your YouTube account.
And then click to allow access
to your account.
If you don't allow access, this
process will not work.
Now switch over to your Xbox
or PS3, and go into
Multiplayer, then
into Theater.
Select the gameplay
that you want.
And while you are watching that
game, record a clip that
is 30 seconds or less.
[GUNFIRE]
-Spy plane standing by.
-Name the clip, save it, and
upload it to your fileshare.
Now get out of viewing
the full game.
And then take your clip from
your fileshare and click
Select for Playback.
Now you'll notice
that the Render
Clip option is available.
So click on that.
And then the clip will be
opened, and it will run
through once.
After, you will see a loading
screen for the clip, which
means that it is being
uploaded and
rendered to the internet.
After a few hours, your clip
should be uploaded to your
YouTube account and to
your fileshare on
callofduty.com/theater.
This part does take some time,
so don't expect the clip to be
there as soon as your rendered
clip is complete.
So in other words, try
to be patient.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Are
you patient, Cliff?
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Be patient.
That is key.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So
this was the user
experience, as you see.
Even though it was not super
straightforward, there were
lots of gamers that actually
found a way
to go through this.
And consequently, we got a lot
of this type of content.
And I think the nice part
about the experience is
there's no need for a capture
card and you can just upload
it directly from your game.
And then the other piece that
wasn't really emphasized too
much is the fact that Call of
Duty has a theater mode where
you can actually edit that
content somehow.
KENJI ARAI: It certainly was
really helpful for us to have
guys like [? Anoj ?]
from our friends at Machinima
to help sort
of educate the community.
And so, like we kind of talked
about earlier, if you do
decide to go down this route of
integrating an API upload
feature into your game,
definitely have
that content prepared.
Because I think users are going
to want to know how to
do it and where it goes.
Instead of having your community
team bombarded with
questions, let a video kind
of speak for it and
speak for you guys.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And again, if
you would like to know more
about this particular
integration, we'll share a
post on our developers page
with the link to the video
from the session and the
presentation slides.
Now let's talk a little
bit about mobile.
So this is something we
did at Google I/O '12.
We talked about integration
into your mobile titles.
So let me show you one of the
options that is getting
traction lately.
In fact, a couple of weeks ago,
we had guys from Kamcord
here that are pursuing this
option quite successfully.
At I/O, we presented jointly
with Dude Perfect.
If you're a basketball fan,
then you know who
Dude Perfect is.
If not, then I highly encourage
you to google Dude
Perfect channel and check out
some of their videos.
But the process for
mobile games looks
something like this.
In the case of Dude Perfect,
actually, the game is written
on top of Unity engine.
And the AV frames from the games
are actually encoded in
their integration
using FFmpeg.
Video frames are encoded using
VP8, so this is a part of the
WebM suite.
Audio frames are encoded
using Vorbis.
Next, the actual corresponding
file is
wrapped in the WebM container.
So again, this is technology
that is actually available
from Google.
So if you look for
webmproject.org, you will see
all the source.
And you're welcome to use it.
Once that is done, then this is
where the YouTube API comes
into the picture.
So you actually have the
audio/video file encoded
wrapped into a WebM container.
And you can use our
RESTful APIs to
push it over to YouTube.
So it's really as
simple as this.
Now, this all happens on the
mobile device, so obviously
there are some challenges as far
as the processing power of
the device and how much time the
user is willing to spend
waiting on it.
Now, on some platforms, the
encoding process can actually
be hardware accelerated.
So this is an area where we see
rapid progress and a lot
of innovation.
I think Kenji--
as I mentioned, he's a
world-famous mobile gamer.
I think he's really looking
forward to getting some of
these clips on YouTube.
KENJI ARAI: Sure.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So one
interesting example that I
always like to bring
up because I have
kids is Talking Tom.
And if any of you guys or gals
in the audience have kids, you
probably have this application
on your phone already.
This is a virtual
pet application.
You can talk to the cat,
interact with the cat.
But one cool feature
of that application
is the YouTube upload.
And they actually co-presented
with us at GDC
earlier in the year.
This is what their integration
looks like.
Again, thanks for allowing us
to share this information,
both at GDC and Google I/O. The
company that builds the
Talking Tom is called Outfit7.
You can download it on your
Android or iOS device.
So in their case, they actually
implemented the local
video rendering and encoding.
It's reasonably low resolution,
low frame rate, so
10 frames per second.
Encoded using the
MOV container--
MPEG4 and AAC audio.
One thing that they've done
a really good job of is
including a lot of metadata
with these uploads.
So if you actually look closely,
you will see that
every upload includes a link
to the actual game.
So in this case, Outfit7
actually now has a franchise,
so there's many characters.
So this was an upload that I
did from the Talking Ben
application.
And he's a really cool,
laid-back dog.
I was told he's modeled after
the Great Lebowski, but I'm
not sure if that's
true or not.
And what you'll see
here is there's a
download link in the metadata.
So please take advantage
of that.
This is free advertising
for your game.
You can just include it as a
part of your metadata during
the upload.
And then when users view the
video on YouTube, they will be
able to click on that link.
And you can take them
wherever you want.
And typically, you can take them
to Google Play so they
can actually download
the application.
Then, tags that are helpful
with video discovery.
This slide shows the
creator's view.
Jeff is actually going to talk
a little bit more about some
of the changes in the tagging
area, but that's another thing
that helps this.
Cliff mentioned a lot of the
video is driven by discovery,
so we show related videos
and so forth.
So people can actually spend
more time on YouTube.
So if you actually do a good job
of the metadata, chances
are that the videos will
get more views.
So let's look at an example--
gameplay video or virtual
pet video.
And I'll give Kenji credit
for finding this one.
I think he's a big fan.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[PURRING]
-Hi, Bruno Mars.
[SINGING]
[GIGGLING]
-I'm lazy.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KENJI ARAI: 5.7 million views.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Almost
6 million views.
That's incredible.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So that's
just amazing.
So this is what you get if you
actually do a good job
integrating.
So finally, let's go through a
quick list of best practices.
I will make this deck available
for you so you can
look at it offline, but a couple
of things to remember.
So first of all, make sure that
you have a developer key
and a full version
two of the API.
You can go to code.google.com/
apis/youtube/dashboard.
And you can get it there.
Use it with your uploads.
You can use direct uploads
or resumable uploads.
Again, this depends on
your architecture.
For mobile games, we recommend
resumable uploads.
So that if you lose
connectivity, you have
actually quite a bit of time to
reestablish the upload and
just upload whatever it
is that was missed.
Next, use developer tags.
So this is a feature that is
frequently overlooked by
developers.
What it allows you to
do is really encode
application-specific metadata in
the video and then use our
search index to actually
find it.
For example, if you're curating
playlists on your
portal, you can use these stacks
to actually figure out
which level the gameplay is
about or what weapons are
being used, and so forth.
So this is entirely up to you
of what you encode in that
information.
And it allows you to actually
offload some of the database
searches onto our
search index.
And as Kenji mentioned, we are
reasonably good at that.
KENJI ARAI: Reasonably.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then,
consider quotas.
Last week, we had a more
in-depth version of our quota
best practices talk.
The starting point for that
is this blog post.
That's something that we always
make sure that partners
think about in their uploads
implementation.
If you have a service-side
system and there's a bunch of
uploads happening in parallel,
make sure that you follow the
quota best practices.
Now, for partners, we have a
content management system--
and this is something that
Kenji and Cliff were
explaining--
that allows you to actually
manage this content once it
gets uploaded.
The first step there is
actually, before you even
launch, make sure that you set
up a content management system
policy for that content and
associate that with a
developer key.
Because this is something that
allows you to actually
automatically claim the content
as soon as YouTube
receives it.
As a part of the upload, we'll
actually apply the policy that
you have designed
to that content.
So this is something you want
to do ahead of time.
Get everything set up.
And when you launch your game,
when the uploads start coming
from your users, you will
actually be able to track
them, analyze them, and then
hopefully monetize them if
that is important to you.
It doesn't seem important
to Kenji.
KENJI ARAI: Why not?
Everything's important to me.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Let me
just explain policies.
Policies are basically rules
that you're going to set once
you're a partner for your
videos or your uploads.
And the policies can take
three different rules.
The first is to monetize it,
so monetize all uploads or
monetize a upload.
The second is to track it.
So you're getting the user data
on those videos and not
monetizing it.
And the third is blocking.
Probably you're not going
to use block.
Obviously, if you're opening
up the API to record your
uploads and upload them through
the API, you're
probably not going to
use that policy.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thanks
for clarifying that.
And finally, encoding
specifications--
so I mentioned WebM,
VP8, Vorbis.
If you use other containers,
other codecs, we have a
detailed list of specifications
that we
recommend--
resolutions, bit rates, and so
forth, all the good stuff.
It's here in the link.
I'll share this deck.
So if you are actually working
on the capture process,
encoding process, then
consider that.
So this concludes our session.
Before we transition to Q&A, I
was hoping that Jeff could
cover some of the recent
developments in the YouTube
blog world.
Jeff, are you on the
line with us?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Still there?
All right.
Over to you.
JEFFREY POSNICK: All right.
Cool.
And thanks, Cliff and Kenji, for
joining us and providing
all that useful information.
And yeah, so we have two recent
blog posts, both of
which have come out since our
last Google Developers Live.
And I wanted to cover
them fairly quickly.
As always, you should refer to
the official blog to read them
yourselves.
It's apiblog.youtube.com,
where you can
find all our posts.
So the first one has to do with
playlist identifiers that
are returned and read
by the API.
So for those who have
ever seen a YouTube
playlist web page--
some sort of page that you go to
on the YouTube website and
you're viewing a playlist--
and you've taken a look
at what the URL is.
You might have noticed that
the identifier for that
playlist, when shown in
the URL bar, has the
prefix pl on it.
And that's been kind of
universal on the website for
about a year or so.
We have not supported that
prefix for playlist
identifiers in the
data API, though.
So a lot of times we'll have
people who had copied a
playlist identifier
from a web page.
They've tried to pass it in to
the API when making a call to
retrieve the contents of the
playlist or something along
those lines.
And they've gotten back an error
indicating, hey, this
playlist doesn't exist.
So basically, what we've done is
added support for playlists
that have that pl prefix
on them and will
both read those values.
So when you're constructing a
URL that has to do with a
playlist, you could include
those prefixed playlist IDs.
Or if you're passing in metadata
and you're updating
playlists or something
like that, you could
pass in those pl values.
But what we're also doing is
returning those playlists with
the prefixes by default.
So if you get back a list of all
the playlists in a given
account or if you do a search
for playlists that match a
certain search term, the
identifiers that you get back
from the API will now include
that pl prefix in
the playlist IDs.
So we are still going to support
old-style un-prefixed
playlist IDs, certainly for
the time being, in read
requests or update requests, so
you could continue to pass
in those un-prefixed
identifiers.
But we do hope that folks, first
of all, are not reading
too much into what
the identifiers
returned by the API is.
I hope there's not folks out
there who wrote codes
thinking, OK, playlist
identifiers are always going
to be X number of
characters long.
And now your code breaks because
it's two characters
longer than it used to be.
So please don't make
those assumptions.
And one thing-- and particularly
keep in mind if
you have a playlist ID that was
stored somewhere in the
database or something, and then
you're comparing it with
a response that you get back
from the data API now.
If your playlist ID did not
include the pl prefix, and you
expected it to be equal to
something you get back from
the API right now, you
might be surprised.
So just keep that in the back of
your head if you happen to
have code that makes those
sorts of assumptions.
So that's one of the changes.
The other change is related to a
recent blog post that we had
on our YouTube creator blog.
And I think folks probably have
also realized this if
they've gone to a YouTube
watch page recently.
And that's basically the fact
that we're not exposing the
keywords or video tags--
there's two different
terms that basically
mean the same thing--
for a given video publicly
anymore.
So if I happen to be a user
who's watching some random
video uploaded on Google
Developers accounts, I won't
see the specific keywords
that have been
used to tag that video.
It's not going to
affect anything
related to Search, though.
So I could continue to search
for YouTube API.
And videos that have been tagged
by the uploader with
the tag YouTube API will show
up in the search results.
So this is just about what
we're exposing to random
people who are viewing
the video.
So that went live on the website
a couple weeks ago.
And what's going to go live
fairly soon in the API--
it's going to go live on the
station server a little bit
later today, and I think in
production next week--
is the fact that we're going
to be pretty much doing the
same thing for API responses.
So if you get a video entry back
from the API now and you
are not authenticated as the
owner of the video, you're
going to see a blank media
keywords element in response.
If you are authenticated as
the owner of the video,
though, you'll continue to
get your keywords back.
And you can continue to add
keywords to new videos that
you upload.
And you can update existing
videos to include whatever
keywords you'd like.
So that doesn't change from the
perspective of the owner
of the video or the uploader
of the video.
So what really is changing is
the public information to
non-authenticated users
that we're returning.
So just please keep in mind
that if you do have an
application that lets people
update the metadata of an
existing video and you
are signed in as the
owner of that video.
When you're reading that video
entry-- like maybe you have an
app that lets you fetch all
your existing videos and
change some of the metadata--
be sure that when you do the
fetching, the initial Gets of
those videos--
that you're properly
authenticated as the owner.
And that way, you'll get back
the media key words.
And you could display
it to the user.
And the user could
make updates.
And you won't end up returning
no media keywords because you
make an unauthenticated request
and accidentally
wiping out all the existing
keywords for the user.
So that's the one probably
most important
thing to keep in mind.
It's a bit of an edge case.
But if you happen to be in that
camp, watch out for that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
And both of them are described
on our blog post in more
detail, right?
JEFFREY POSNICK: Absolutely.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Jeremy, any questions
on the moderator?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah,
we have a couple.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We have
a few minutes left.
JEREMY WALKER: I think we
have like three minutes.
I'll run through these
pretty quickly.
Quick plug--
don't forget, we are hiring.
So go to
developers.google.com/jobs.
We have some openings.
We'd love to hear from you.
So if you are interested,
check that out.
We have about three questions.
One is about using Chrome
with Flash and
recording with a webcam.
Basically, they say it's
a little bit laggy.
So our response to that is let
us know the bug ID and.
We can bug the right people.
So just kind of follow up
with that if you could.
But if we don't have that,
we can't do a whole lot.
So that would be great.
AutoPlay--
we hear this a lot.
This is on iOS-- is basically,
I'm using
Embed with the iFrame.
And AutoPlay doesn't
work on iOS.
That's just something that's
part of Apple.
They don't let you
autoplay videos.
iOS just doesn't do that.
Jeff, I don't know if you want
to add anything to that.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah, this
definitely comes up quite a
bit in the Google group.
And I have recently put together
a post in the Google
group that kind of spells out
exactly what's going on and
points to Apple's official
documentation.
I'm doing my best to convince
people that this really is not
something that YouTube is doing
deliberately, but this
is a policy that Apple
has in place for
fairly sensible reasons.
And there are ways of working
around it, if you happen to be
using a packaged, official
iOS application that's
using a UI web view.
And in that case, you can change
the defaults to allow
playbacks by default.
But if you are just opening a
web page by default, you can't
do that or you just can't
do that at all.
So check the Google group.
And maybe I'll post a link to
my response to the Google
group in our Google+ account,
just to highlight it to folks
who might be watching at home
who want to read that.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yeah.
And then to follow up on that,
there was one last question
around the iFrame API, saying
it doesn't work
in Chrome and Safari.
And I think it's just that
the video doesn't play.
So Jeff has already posted a
link to follow up on that.
And I think it's just kind
of the rehash of
what we just discussed.
So those are all
the questions.
We still have a minute left.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Can we do
a coast-to-coast wave?
Jeremy, start it off.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Ready?
Whoa.
Jeff.
Back to the West Coast.
Jeremy, start again.
Whoa.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this
is why those guys--
[INAUDIBLE].
Oh, they have fun
all the time.
That's why they never work.
CLIFF SAMANIEGO: Thanks,
everyone.
JEREMY WALKER: Thanks
for joining us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Thank you guys.
See you next week--
Wednesday, the usual slot.
JEREMY WALKER: Bye, everybody.
[MUSIC PLAYING]